okay yes this is happening no first of
all thank you to care of for sponsoring
this video I'll talk to you more about
that company that I love very much
towards the end of this video so let's
get on with it hi my name is Grace help
if you do not know now you know your
life is different now a few days ago I
went on Twitter and I asked you guys am
I about to do a magic trick if I hope
with my hands and there's quarters in
both of my thumbs I'm gonna lose my
position I know I asked you guys if you
would be down for the idea of be doing a
weekly or bi-weekly video that caps
lates
my reactions thoughts theories etc is
around reality television because I
spend the majority of my time watching
reality TV and I've always thought of it
as my shameful little secret and you
know what no I won't say I'm super proud
of it but I'm pretty okay with it and
that's why I've decided that I should
utilize all the time and mental energy
that I put into that type of programming
and then filter it into this type of
programming it's like a fun way to
upcycle procrastination I'm a genius and
a lot of you seemed on board with that
idea too so here we are I don't have a
name for this series I'd love your
suggestions leave them in the comments
down below I just want to be able to
have someone some few people to be able
to express my thoughts and feelings
about reality TV - that aren't my
boyfriend because I forced him to watch
too much of it already and aren't my dog
because she is a dog I don't know
exactly how to do this so today's gonna
be just a real brief clunky version of
what might evolve into something more
structured ask you guys what shows that
you wanted me to talk about and I got an
overwhelming response - bachelor in
paradise and are you the one so that's
what we're talking about today I just
watched the most recent episode from
Tuesday night of bachelor in paradise
right before they saw I'm all fired up
on this
give me a baseball bat and a pinata okay
let's start with batch in paradise I
have to let you guys know I'm a late
comer to the bachelor franchise not sure
what season I started maybe Ashley
season or the the race car drivers
season the boring one so some of the
people from bachelor in paradise I don't
fully know but you don't really I guess
they need to know them to know that
they're hungry for attention and they
look great in a bathing suit
here are some thoughts I started to
write down five is like the most excited
I've been to make a video and then looks
like prep I haven't done for making a
video because I'm so excited about
making these kinds of videos I hope you
guys enjoyed this JPJ and Taoiseach all
the way I love this couple so much JPJ
is like Keanu Reeves from Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure meets like a Sprouse
twin tatius like Michelle Obama decided
to go on spring break or just the
perfect couple they are my royal couple
so far I came out of nowhere I was not
prepared it was like the oxygen mask
came down and I had not had a flame
tenant tell me what to do with it yet he
memorized a Shakespearean excerpt from
Romeo and Juliet for her and he tried so
hard and for some reason it wasn't
cringy it's really sweet if any other
doofus on that Beach tried to do that I
would have been like no and thrown a
shoe at my television which is fine
because I don't wear shoes cuz right up
until that point I kept thinking oh no
JPJ hasn't formed any real connections
with anyone other than what seems like
friendship and I don't want him to get
voted off because he's just great TV and
then slam bam thank you ma'am
Stacia is a great catch is fun and
interesting and like very wise she seems
very wise JPJ just seems fun
light-hearted he's got a cartoon
character voice what was that
Nickelodeon cartoon of the kids that
were at the beach house rocket power
yeah he sounds like a voice from rocket
pepper there a powerful rocket I'm all
in on them Lake but guess so Mik to me
you look as I got some it best I mean
thumbs do great
look somes encourage you discourage you
get you places he seems to be doing all
of that with all of the women like
became like America's Sweetheart after
his season of The Bachelor because he
sincerely seemingly got his heart broken
which I get but seeing him on bachelor
in paradise he's all twitchy and anxious
and you know what kind of people are
twitchy and anxious people that are full
of lives yo who isn't twitchy and
anxious JPJ all the way now blink is
into Hannah Jean and Hannah gee is like
a Cabbage Patch doll that went through
puberty but I actually understand Blake
and Hannah Gees getting together I think
that they both became America's
Sweethearts after their seasons of The
Bachelor Bachelorette and they got like
projected to this adoration on a grand
level and they didn't really know how to
handle it sometimes I think that they're
like innocent people that got thrust
into this situation and I really truly
don't know exactly how to operate like
if you took like a homeschool kid to the
back of a Spencer's gift shop and just
say go nuts but then on the other hand I
feel like there are adults and they're
smart and they know what they're doing
part of me thinks what if there's like
an ugly duckling situation like both of
them were dorks when they were younger
and then like puberty and some things
did some good things to their things and
now people are like you're super hot and
now they have all this attention on them
and so now they kind of have the power
and control they never had when they
were down here and so they want all of
it because they never had it before if
and when they fit up they act as if they
have no idea how they've done that both
of their natural resting faces are shock
and disbelief just like huh what blink
blink blink huh
I can't believe no I you felt what I'm
sorry
now I blink blink blink blink not every
single feeling that someone tells you
should be that shocking to you
unfortunately for Dylan which sucks it's
like she clearly came there with mo of
wanting to see what happens with Blake
and Blake came with a bunch of baggage
and she wasn't expecting that so she
kept kind of a distance but then when he
pursued she was say I want that too it's
um it's like nerd prom I think they're
gonna end up together and you know what
quite frankly I could give a [ __ ]
kind of boring yeah I feel bad for Dylan
but it's like they had this pre-plan in
this scenario what I would like to see
thrown in is a wrench I want to watch
one of them go nuts they're all a bunch
of tools sitting I watch it I love it
Christian the new kid Christian is so
fun to watch for me because it feels
like he is literally the new kid in
school that doesn't understand how the
rules of the school work all the other
cast members like know how to act on TV
and not they know when to cry wouldn't
it be emotional when to kiss how'd it
kiss like all these certain like they
know all the nuances of cameras and
producers and that sort of thing and he
just comes guns-a-blazing it's like the
school says hey lunch is at 11:30 and
he's like no I'm having my lunch right
now I'm eating it off Nicole's ass and I
don't care how many cameras watch me I
have no regard for my friends and family
that will be watching this in the future
nor hers I want this and this is what
I'm getting oh it's fantastic he doesn't
give a sh he had a date card he took no
longer like he took her out get what you
want because he was voted off on the
very first night and his season of The
Bachelorette I feel like he's bold and
unjaded and that's very exciting whereas
Jordan on the other hand is bold but
like so jaded like he knows who his
character is for TV and he just plays
them to that and that's not as
interesting to me because it just feels
fake but I guess that's supposed to be
it so I should be fine with that but the
fact that these two get in a fight over
a pinata what's more real about that
Christian sets up this date for Nicole
with a full pinata like on the beach and
then the other guy this is how much I
remember the other guy clay Leia tries
to go in and be a big band
is so cringy to watch someone whose
natural state is not alpha and is more
beta try to be alpha oh and then Jordan
decides that he's gonna step in and bust
open the pinata because that's what
don't men do and the greatest part of
all of this is when you zoom out a
little bit on this show Christian didn't
come there with the pinata he didn't go
through TSA with a [ __ ] pinata some
PA on set had to like run into town to
buy a pinata and lug it back so that
they could pretend that Christian
brought this specifically for Nicole and
then Jordan stomps up right there I felt
like I was watching the end of the movie
big where like Jordan walked over as an
adult and then slowly regressed into
like an 11 year old boy as he walked
over so stupid
they ended the episode at the very
beginning of them physically having an
altercation I hate physical violence
very very much also what do you expect
is gonna happen when you go over and you
rip up someone's technically their
property really dumb all the way around
so we'll see what happens next week Oh
what are the rest of my notes
oh poor cam teens great well Demi is so
much more likable to me on this whole
season because she's much more
vulnerable and she's got so many more
layers so that's cool Kristina seems a
little insecure Lea sassy this season
don't know if I like that did anyone
ever check on whether Katie actually had
a stroke or not there's been a Kevin
this whole time all right those are my
thoughts for right now on bachelor in
paradise let's get into are you the one
and I haven't written out my notes on
this at all so I'm going to be a little
bit all over the place are you the one
this season is wild I don't even know
how to explain the show to people that
haven't watched it when I first watch
this show I thought it was just like a
dating game show I didn't fully
understand the concept of it and then
when I realized that they're all trying
to win a million dollars collectively as
a house and I was like this is genius
genius is too big of a word for what
this show is but it's good and i'ma
watch it this is the fluid season of are
you the one which makes it extra juicy
because everyone is fair game
which also gives me extra anxiety
there's so many different like
mathematical combinations they could all
pair up dr. Frankie what's she doing she
actually I know she comes in and she
just goes heartbreak is hard right and
they're all like yeah alright see ya I
think it's great it's an addition I
think that they probably had some notes
about like you're not actually helping
them develop their tools to be better
partners in the search for their ideal
partner so you know step in the right
direction here's their one big thing
about this show that I've noticed and
let me know if you've known as this to a
lot of times they all speak very
articulately and eloquently and then
they'll get into their truth booths and
it comes out of nowhere that they all
adopt the same type of like weird
slang twang speech that they do to be
its most prevalent and bathe that she'll
be like you knew from the jump but this
and I ain't about that oh girl hit that
ho and I'm like I thought you were like
a little pixie nerd like tight but maybe
I'm judging a book by the cover I don't
know and it's always bothers me with the
hosts like you guys are so on a mermaid
party tonight and then they suddenly all
have holographic mermaid under the seat
garb this is not spontaneous also you
guys party every night you have you're
stuck in a house together like every
night is a party also the slo-mo shots
of them partying looks so good
I love this like the close-up shots have
been like grinding on each other and
like champagne is spraying everywhere
and they're like making out it's all hot
and sexy and glistening and blah and
then they just like pull out a little
bit and then they're just sort of like
oh I want more than that juxtaposition
oh we got going on Jonathan and Bessette
I'm rooting for you I think you guys are
great you will have the coolest closet
in your house of any couple I will
probably ever see get that going Justin
and Max they seem sweet I don't think
they're a mad
but they seemed sweet and I think that's
gonna destroy Justin and if that happens
I feel like we need to all keep an eye
on Justin okay nor nor is not boring
also Norris angry drunk voice it's like
this scary this weirdest like she ate
ten packs of cigarettes and turned into
a mob boss honey I want to listen to it
[Music]
was go Paige what a fun dating game the
crux of all is Kai I don't having about
Kai suite are desperately seeking love
in all of the places right and wrong
kai might be a little bit like Blake is
that crazy to say I didn't feel a lot of
attention and love and self-worth at a
certain point in their life and now feel
all of those things and want all of
those things all of it all of it and
then when it's with everyone else's [ __ ]
then they go huh
maybe it's stuff like this it gets
people out of that pattern behavior
maybe it's stuff like this that
amplifies that pattern behavior I don't
know I'm not a psychologist I'm just a
girl that chooses to watch TV instead of
wash her hair Jenna gym is great why
isn't everyone flocking to get with
Jenna
she is smart she's funny she's beautiful
she's like a mom in the house she's got
a Harry Potter tattoo like she's a total
sweetheart
Amber's also a total sweetheart but also
I think she's a sneaky temptress teach
their own maybe they're each other's
perfect match who knows also who washes
the sheets in the boom-boom room they
get washed right who washes any of the
sheets in the entire house the sheets
get washed why don't we see any of that
footage oh and then there's Danny who
looks like like a skinnier version of
bolt from 90-day fiance another reality
franchise that we'll get to eventually
Danny just wants to get the math right
and win the money my favorite part of
the episode though was to win Kai
drunkenly was professing his love to
Jenna
Danny was trying to give Chi fook is
clear they were so drunk and Jenna asked
Danny to leave and he just left them
food there for them it's a sweetheart oh
my god it was such a sweet little moment
did anyone else catch that I also like
to that sometimes you can tell that
they're like clearly super stoned and
I'm like oh this is fun they get high on
this show they don't show them getting
high but I imagine that they are
probably at a tropical paradise that has
a lot of grass whoa full outfit change
because here's where I tell you about
care of who is sponsoring today's video
thank you so much care of your of is a
subscription service that delivers
vitamins and supplements that are
catered to your specific health needs
are you looking to get better sleep are
you looking to manage stress are you
looking for energy all of these things
can be accomplished what you need to do
is you need to take their online quiz
it's really simple it takes five minutes
ask to a lot of personalized questions
about your lifestyle your fitness goals
they can create personalized
scientifically backed recommendations
for you and your body and you need zinia
necessities based on the results the
quiz
Cara will send you little supplement and
vitamin caps personalized just for you
look at that it says it says hi grace on
it now I have to take these every day
because it has addressed me by my name
also you can modify your subscription at
any time based on like how your needs
change it's also vegan and vegetarian
options out there for you guys so you're
getting all the nutrients that those
dietary restrictions require and the
best part of this is you can get 25% off
your first order if you go to take care
of comm and then enter the promo code
grace H again go to take care of comm
enter the promo code grace H also I just
throw like a couple packs in my suitcase
when I go travel and do shows over the
weekend and it really balances out all
the unhealthy lifestyle choices I
when I perform so at least that's what
my scientifically backed knowledge is
recommending for myself okay my thoughts
on our u21 haven't fully been thought
out so that's all I have for right now
based on my memory of watching the last
episode let me know what you guys think
in the comments down below also let me
know what shows you want me to talk
about in the future and how this
structure should go if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to this YouTube
channel I make videos but at least
sometimes cuz this will keep me going
other than that I don't know one
homepage was goal page